hello everyone welcome to the itcs talk
on an algorithmic breach between having
an edit distance I am bonus and this is
a joint work with LSR Goldenberg
kusumaka and Robert Krauthammer
this is the outline of the talk we'll
start with an introduction by motivating
the problem that we study in this paper
followed by the main technical
contribution of this work and then I
will wrap it up with some open questions
well this work is about sequence
comparisons
in many applications we measure
similarity between strings
these applications include computational
biology where you have to measure
similarities between DNA and RNA
sequences pattern recognition text
processing information retrieval and so
on
two main measures subsequent
similarities are Hamming distance and
edit distance in Hamming distance you
compare character by character and you
are looking for substitutions minimum
number of substitutions that can convert
X into y so in the first example in the
example on the top Hamming distance is
3. an added distance in in addition to
substitution you also allow insertions
and deletions so another way of if we
are using at a distance to convert X to
Y could be like you delete this C you
insert this C over here and you
substitute this H with a K so with three
edits you can also convert with one
insertion one deletion and one
substitution you can also convert X to Y
so edit distance is three of course you
could have done just three substitutions
in this case uh to convert X to y
here is another example where if you are
only allowing Hamming distance you have
to substitute seven characters out of
ten so having distance is 7 whereas for
the same example like if you are
allowing insertion and deletion you can
convert X to Y just by doing two edits
you just have to delete this p and
insert this K over here so with two
insertion and deletions you can convert
X to Y so edit distance is much more
versatile much more robust and it gives
you the real similarities and
differences I mean among among sequences
however Hamming distance is cheaper to
compute you can compute having distance
in linear time you can approximate
having distance we are between with
arbitrary Precision in some linear time
whereas for 80 distance I can exact
computation of any distance requires
quadratic time and list on exponential
time hypothesis is is false and also
like sub linear time complexity of added
distance like we don't have any constant
Factor approximation for example that
can compute and it is approximate edit
distance in sublinear type
so there is a huge gap between
computational complexity of having
distance and edit distance
so what makes edit distance so hard well
insertion and deletions gives you much
more flexibility and makes your
algorithm design much more harder indeed
and in and these are insertion deletions
are in shortcut indulse these are really
needed for real life sequence
comparisons however in many practical
applications the number of intels are
much fewer than number of substitutions
you can look into our itcs paper where
you have provided multiple references
they are mainly coming from
computational biology where the
differences in the sequences are
predominated by number of substitutions
though there are few windows that need
to be handled
so the questions that we are asking is
like can we design fast algorithms
faster algorithms for the case of edit
distance with few Windows uh is it more
like having distance or is it more like
edit distance can we provide an
interpolation between the complexities
of having distance and edit distance
from linear to quadratic by modifying
the substitution to indulgation
to do so we Define new metric uh one is
where we assign different cost for
substitutions and substitutions are
cheaper windows are expensive so for
example you can assign a substitution
cost of one over 10 whereas one Intel
will cost you one so this naturally
favors more substitutions 10 times more
substitutions than intels or there could
be another way of modeling this
scenarios that you assign different
budgets for substitutions and in the
same is you ask hey return me an
alignment with case substitutions and Ki
in delves where KS is much higher than
Ki
in the paper we consider both these
different ways of modeling substitution
versus intels but in this talk I am
going to focus on the first one where we
have assigned by you assign different
cost substitutions are cheaper
industrial expensive
and precisely we Define this mu metric
Eda a is a parameter greater than equal
to one integers and e d a X Y is the
minimum cost of edit operation needed to
convert X into y by substitution cost 1
over a and Intel cost 1.
here is an example if you set a equal to
2 so substitution cost 1 over 1 over 2
which is half in this example if you
delete this a and if you add this B over
here so with two intels you can convert
X to Y so Intel cost will be 2. here is
another way of converting X to Y where
you do a substitution in the first
character A to B then a substitution
over here b2a another substitution here
A to B so with three substitutions you
can also convert x 2 Y and what is the
cost of phase substitution that is three
over two so three substitutions is
cheaper than two indels
if a is equal to 1 well in that case you
get back your normal edit distance or
everything has uniform cost in that case
on the other hand if you set a equal to
n this length of the string then
substitution is so much cheaper that you
don't want to have any insertion
deletions at all so now you are in the
Hamming distance region therefore by
varying a you can have a nice
interpolation from Hamming distance to
edit distance
a equal to 1 inside the distance equal
to n is having distance and what are the
algorithmic challenges the algorithmic
challenges are to interpolate between
the computational complexities of known
algorithms for having distance linear
time and added distance quadratic time
find good approximations for Eda
possibly in sub-linear time and then
from computational complexity we want to
understand whether it's possible to
provide lower bounds for Eda and if that
lower bound also kind of interpolates
between having an edit distance
we look into all of these in this paper
and our main contributions is to provide
an OnePlus Epsilon Factor approximation
for Eda with a sublinear running time
for switchable choice of parameters here
I should mention
irrespective of the choice of parameters
getting a poly logarithmic approximation
for normalated distance in some linear
time we don't know how to do that
uh so there is a big gap here between
like what we can provide in this paper
what we can provide for ETA and what is
known for normal edit distance so we can
do so much better for Eda compared to
edit distance of course it depends on
the value of a because if a is equal to
1 we get back normal edit distance
normal so that's that's why this this is
sublinear running time for suitable
choice or parameters but we should
mention we should remember that
irrespective of the choice of parameters
for
normally at a distance we don't know how
to do that even even close to that in
addition we also provide algorithms for
exact computation and show tight
conditional lower bounds for Eda
a for one plus Epsilon approximation
Factor this is the running time we get
it's n over a Epsilon Cube plus a k q
what is k k is the optimum Eda distance
and it is in this new definition of
added distance between X and Y
so you can see if a is large that is
there are many substitutions and K is
not too large then
and this is sublinear running time if
suppose a is n to the 1 4 then K is
strictly less than n to the 1 4 then we
get a sub linear running time and how
should you say the set the value for a
well a good value for a will be the
substitution to Intel ratio that you are
expecting in your in your application
okay so now let's look into this theorem
and uh I will try to give you some main
ideas like how what behind behind this
theorem
well the goal is like we are given X and
Y which satisfies the Eda is less than
equal to K and we want to find an
alignment with cos one at most one plus
Epsilon times k
here is an observation which is simple
but crucial for our algorithm that is we
can allow Epsilon a substitutions
between consecutive Windows since
Epsilon is substitutions only cost and
additional Epsilon cost right because
for every substitution is 1 over a cost
so Epsilon a substitutions overall will
cost a X cost and X Drive silent in the
in the cost which can be absorbed in one
in the because one Intel cost one and we
are we are fine with one plus Epsilon
approximation so essentially Epsilon a
substitutions are you can you can do
those for free when you are considering
Eda and you are looking for one plus
Epsilon approximation
another important ingredient which has
been very crucial for the development of
normality distance as well is LC queries
longest common extension queries so what
is longest common extension query like
you are given two strings capital x and
capital Y you are also given two
positions in those two strings small X
and small y if you want to answer lcdxy
that is the largest substring starting
at small X and small y uh which has
Hamming distance strictly less than t
okay so for example if you are looking
for lc3 query uh you see that that is
four because like if you're looking at
substrings of length 5 then there are
three mismatches so therefore uh the
longest that you can go from starting at
X and Y with
um less than strictly less than three
mismatches is four so LC three X Y is 4.
we can approximate we can have an
approximate notion of lce queries which
is given by LCD comma C which is any
value between LCD query and LC CD query
so for example LC 3xy is 4 as we saw in
the last example LC six x y here is 10
so LC 3 comma 2 can return you any
answer between lc3 and lc6 that is
between 4 to 10 so that's how we can
approximate you can have an approximate
version of LC queries
this LC queries once you know how to
compute this LC queries you can use them
to compute edit distance let's look at
normal edit distance what how we can do
it so you consider values normal at a
distance bounded by threshold K okay so
here you are considering values between
0 and K in your dynamic programming
travel you are considering diagonals s
between minus B to v y because like if
the value V can only appear in diagonals
from minus B to V and if you are
considering diagonals beyond that they
are starting the starting values in
those diagonals will be higher than b so
you just need to look at diagonals from
minus B to B
and for each diagonal in that range you
compute the highest row with that
particular value V so for example
suppose you are looking at the main
diagonal here and you know the highest
highest row where the value V equal to 1
has appeared is over here and similarly
for the two neighboring diagonals now
you want to compute the highest rows in
the diagonals minus 2 to 2 for Value 2.
so how do you do so you look at the main
diagonal if you're if you're here you
take a substitution and you come over
here if you're here you do an in doubt
then you come over here similarly if
you're here you do a Intel you come over
here so for all these three cases you
come over here now your cost is 2 and
now you want to do an LC one query to to
move as far as possible without making
any other errors so that's what you do
you do an LC one query you reach here
and that's the that's the maximum
highest row that you can go 2 in
diagonal 0 with a value of 2.
so similarly you can compute the the
highest Row for each of the five
diagonals for the value of 2 and so on
so overall like if your values are
ranging from 0 to K there are 2K plus 1
diagonals to consider in each diagonally
we'll make KLC queries overall you will
be doing a k Square LC queries for
normal edit distance computation you can
do a preprocessing linear time
preprocessing so that this K Square LC
queries each of these cells required is
can be answered in constant time so
overall we will have a running term of n
plus K squared
now for exact Eda queries we'll follow
the same
setup except that now the values V
instead of going in an increment of one
will go in and increment of one over a
so you will look at 0 1 over 8 2 over a
3 over a up to K for every value we will
look at the diagonals they don't change
from minus V to V because for Intel you
are paying plus one for every Intel and
now for every
diagonal divided again Computing the
highest row with the value V same logic
using for the exact distance computation
just with these more different
increments of 1 over a for the values of
V so that gives you the exact Eda
computation we show that this algorithm
is the best that you can do in terms of
conditional lower bounds
now for approximately so how do we
modify the exact Eda algorithm for
approximate DDA computation so the first
thing instead of going through all the
values 0 1 over a 2 over a 3 over a we
increment these values with a gap of
Epsilon so we go in an increment of 0
Epsilon to Epsilon K because anyway we
can absorb this x Epsilon Gap in our
approximation factor and another another
point is instead of doing the LC one
queries as I have told you like Epsilon
a substitutions are free so we will be
doing an LC Epsilon a queries and also
like we can do an approximate LC Epsilon
a queries approximation by one plus
Epsilon Factor because anyway we are
allowing one plus Epsilon factors so
that's the main change you are going
through
in the course of granularity for the
values b instead of releasing LC exact
lc1 queries you are releasing
approximate LC Epsilon aquaries for
every diagonal and that should help you
in speeding up your running time so
that's the mobile algorithm to get an on
one plus Epsilon approximate an
approximation factor for Ada
so the main technical challenge is like
how do you do approximate LCD queries D
will be Epsilon a so lcf LCD queries
within one plus Epsilon Factor very fast
to do so we'll be using
um
we'll be using a sampling technique so
let's look at some ideas like uh for the
for uh for a sampling algorithm to
compute LC approximate LCD queries first
here we should note that for lcg queries
the maximum sampling rate that we can
hope for is one over deal because we
have to catch one error right out of the
errors so really we cannot think cannot
expect to have a sampling rate lower
than 1 over t so suppose I sample X at a
rate of 1 over D and then we return the
first samples I such that X plus I is
not doesn't match with Y plus I we have
this small X and small y positions from
where we are Computing this LCD query
okay so that's fine but then what is the
sampling rate are we looking at in y for
every position sample position in X
there are K possible shifts to consider
and that means the sampling rate at y
that we are looking at is K Over D which
is too high so this night sampling rate
doesn't give you the ideal sampling rate
of 1 over D for X and Y
another way to get uniform sampling from
X and Y could be that you sample X and Y
at a rate of 1 over square root of D in
that case X plus I and Y plus I did
together sampled with probability one
over D so you can compute LCD queries
but again the sampling rate is 1 over
square root of D which is way too high
than what we are expecting a sampling
rate of 1 over t
G case 19 this is a paper on Gap at the
distance from Fox 2019 they also needed
to compute LC approximate LC queries not
LCD queries though so they wanted to
compute lc1 queries with an
approximation factor of d uh so for that
what they did whenever you are starting
from a particular position X and Y in
capital x and capital Y they have a
waiting period in this waiting period
they look at all possible shapes where
the matches are exact
ly and that helps them to eliminate some
other shapes because they are really
looking for lc1 query so for all those
shapes where there are at least one area
they can eliminate those diagonals and
for the other diagonals the the in the
waiting periods the two strings X and Y
are matching exactly so once they match
in the waiting period And there are
multiple shapes where they are matching
that implies the strings are periodic so
then instead of trying for every
possible shift which was a problem for
our knife sampling method they check for
periodicity and once the periodicity
break then that means there is a
potential mismatch
and that's how they can get a 1 over D
sampling rate
so we want to use their idea but there
are multiple bottlenecks here so first
of all in the previous case in gks 19
Whenever there is a Whenever there is a
particular shift where there is at least
one error in the waiting period you can
eliminate that shift because they are
looking for lc1 query we cannot do that
we are looking for lcg queries so even
if there is a shift for which there is a
mismatch in the waiting period we cannot
eliminate that so which means we have to
handle with like even in the waiting
period we are really looking for almost
periodic strings not periodic strings so
we have to handle almost periodic
strings and not every period break is a
mismatch so these two
um make our methods make make our
algorithms much more complicated to
handle almost almost periodic strings
where every period break is not a
mismatch so overall this is the
um
comparisons that we get the fourth row
is our work so we get an OnePlus Epsilon
approximation Factor LC we are returning
LCD queries with one plus Epsilon
approximation Factor the pre-processing
time is n over D so we do get one over D
sampling rate we have a query time of
order of t k this is basically you have
to spend a few more times and more time
for every period break in order to
explore the local regions there to find
for mismatches
whereas in G case 19 you can only they
can only answer lc1 query they have
ordered or the approximation much higher
approximation
pre-processing time is innovative which
we match their query time is faster
uh on the other hand LCD queries the
only other verb that can answer LCD
queries with one plus Epsilon
approximation is BC at 20 but they have
a much higher sampling rate though but
lower query time so overall this is this
is the trade-offs that we get between
pre-processing time and query time for
ncdxy and that helps us to get our
running time of n over a plus and AKQ
foreign
questions the main open question is can
you improve the running time of our
algorithm at the expense of what's
approximation Factor so here we are
looking for OnePlus Epsilon
approximation factor for normal edit
distance we do not know such
approximation factors in sublinear time
whereas the query we know how to have
better running time there like we can
get rid of the polycar terms for normal
sublinear terminated distance
computation and we also know how to go
beyond in a worry like when we are
looking for higher approximation errors
so the question is like can we also do
those things when we are looking for Eda
if can we get better running time maybe
with a worse approximation factors okay
so thank you for listening